2026년 5월 26일 화요일 미국 증시 유약입니다.
금일 미국 증시는 상승 마감했습니다.
미국의 이란 공습으로 중동 평화 협상에 대한 불안감이 커졌지만
AI 산업에 대한 기대감이 이를 상세했습니다.
반도체 기업들이 상승세를 주도하며 S&P500 지수는 사상 최고치를 기록했습니다.
S&P500 지수는 0.61%, 기술주 중심의 나스닥 지수는 1.19% 상승 마감했습니다.
마이크론은 UBS 애널리스의 낙관적 평가 속에 19% 급등하며 시가총액 1조 달러를 넘어섰습니다.
UBS는 마이크론이 맺은 장기 공급 계약의 수혜를 근거로 주가가 현재보다 2배 이상 더 오를 여력이 있다고 평가했습니다.
동종 메모리 반도체 기업인 시게이트와 웻선 디지털 역시 각각 4%, 5% 오르며 동반 상승했습니다.
퀄컴은 틱톡의 모회사 바이트댄스와 AI 측 공급 계약을 체결했다는 블룸버그 통신 보호사입니다.
트럼프 대통령은 미 중부사령부는 화요일 이른 시각 이란 남부지역에서 자위적 차원의 공습을 단행했다고 발표했습니다.
트럼프 대통령 또한 휴전 연장과 호르무즈협 재개방을 논의하는 회담이 진행 중이라고 전했습니다.
다만 미 중부사령부는 화요일 이른 시각 이란 남부지역에서 자위적 차원의 공습을 단행했다고 발표했습니다.
중부사령부 대변인은 파격 목표물 가운데 미사일 발사대가 있었습니다.
이란의 공습 소식 이후 유가는 다소 반등했으나 서부 텍사스함 원유는 결국 2.81% 하락한 배럴당 94.89달러에 마감했습니다.
한편 마르코 루비오 미 국무장관은 이란과의 분쟁을 종식하기 위한 최종 합의에는 며칠이 더 소요될 수 있다며 신중한 입장을 보였습니다.
이와 관련해 이란 타스님 통신은 이란 정부가 해외에 동결된 240억 달러 교육을 받았습니다.
이와 관련해 이란 정부가 해외에 동결된 240억 달러 교육을 받았습니다.
경제 지표 측면에서는 전쟁으로 인한 물가 상승 우려로 현재 경제 상황에 대한 불안 심리가 커지면서 5월 미국 소비자 신뢰 지수가 소폭 하락했습니다.
이제 시장은 다가오는 목요일에 발표돼 개인 소비 지출 물가 지수와 GDP 데이터를 주목하고 있습니다.
캐피탈닷컴의 화열로다는 시장은 전쟁이 결국 평화적으로 마무리될 가능성에 무게를 두고 있으며 탄탄한 기업 실적과 성장 기대가 다시 매수세를 자극하고 있다.
APL 파이낸셜의 제프리 로치는 현재 물가 부담을 감안하면 소비지 심리가 더 크게 위축될 수 있었지만 소비자들은 연말로 갈수록 고용 여건이 나아질 것으로 기대하고 있다.
바이탈 노얼리지의 아단 크리사플린은 이란과의 협상 타결 기대감과 소비지 심리가 더 크게 위축될 수 있었지만 소비자들은 연말로 갈수록 고용 여건이 나아질 것으로 기대하고 있다.
2026년 5월 27일 수요일 주요 일정 살펴보겠습니다.
경제지표는 23시 리치몬드 여는 서비스업 질수, 02시 미국 5년물 국채경매, 04시 55분 연준 코 기사가 예정되어 있습니다.
말필 복지부 dobrze,진행 cuidado가 Increase promote
제주도 중축전의 두 병목이öllporte 책정 선 vraag을 통해 FINAL시 eher 비해서 따뜻하게 조칠 방안을 계획해서 계속 integ string을yez고 돼 우화대전 sam선 충전 도입 들겠습니다.
까 제일 잘 굉장히ene
review
set
Ini
통해 또 leader transitionstart a diesel entities and if there were ver.